dragon fruit she big great
[Music]
[Music]
if you're well mafia there he came right
anyway nonetheless
babban and I've done a bad job this
morning so what I do I worked out at a
meeting with Matt Higgins with the
Steven Ross crew there my business
partner I went and met a new potential
client I did a couple phone calls we
knit we announced a Badgley our sign
kicker from the University of Miami it's
all about the you and now I'm gonna pure
Wow to make things happen
what's the we're still figuring we're
still figuring it out ourselves son and
the truth is it doesn't work that way
one video can change everything do you
understand you make my man you're making
24 you're making television commercials
the only difference is there's more
attention and you get more at-bats
there's three things that are happening
you're getting more at-bats you're doing
three instead of one a lot more people
are seeing it so it can penetrate
culture and and the client is paying a
lot less for it than they would have
then you alternate that's why it's right
it doesn't go beyond that got it you
want to hear something amazing we only
have ancillary beat the hero we do a
blog it never gets seen as much as the
one minute clips we get out of the blog
only ancillary beeps now this is very
long form yeah three minute videos are
actually actually if I was actually i
retake my thing because if I was to make
a three minute rants right now it would
be doubt the ancillary like I made the
greatest video ever that would have
gotten 150 million views but babban
didn't have audio in the Milwaukee
Airport shooters that's right blog the
greatest video it was Australia the
greatest video I ever made that would
have been my true 200 million viewed
video on Facebook babban [ __ ] up
all right watch your pan yeah until it's
all data that or a meet late tonight
about nice to meet you have a great day
oh my god I'm such a tag line for our
brand hi-low [ __ ] the middle
but that's what it that's what it is the
middle tag but that's like what my
belief is like so that's what it is
though the middle is where everybody's
losing like that's where everybody's
losing yeah yep yo what up team Gary be
account it's me Gary Gary be in Vegas do
my thing at CS Babbitt hustling it's
gonna be back 2018 what a [ __ ]
dismantle 2018 you think we did work in
17 [ __ ] 18
tell me how are you yeah real quick Gary
we appreciate you down okay brother
just go to meeting up a beginner
how are you now take a picture percent
man my man I will say well anyway
hey you doing good yeah I didn't know
you're gonna be out here I was just here
I was doing a couple speaking engagement
and I was I think was home he was like
Gary and Mike cousin good question
probably let's take a face-to-face we're
here yeah I'm but as soon as I knew you
were available I cants up some stuff hey
get some 18 years old he goes I'm right
there with you there's no school team
because I cope with Gary Vee and he does
long story because I think through some
issues with school and brother like this
long story short it has changed my life
is now 18 he runs this like he runs his
company and he's got it goes I've got
this entrepreneur house I'm doing South
by Southwest I want this to be out of it
there's not recharge you man that's just
so real cause I just need to be involved
to visit like 20 my visit there we're
doing entrepreneurs because we're gonna
create content
14 this kids 18 now and he's coming up
to me yeah people like that assente and
giving a business gardening and he's
given to me value for free
he didn't he said we're perfect like you
know Georgie is unlike all right now I'm
teaching them how to win it's so much
bigger than people realize okay
[Applause]
[Music]
hi guys hi hi I'm honest we go look at
culture and the consumer and we put out
you know a 2 minute 14 second cartoon of
because that's what the [ __ ] we decided
I could have sold that to her in that
moment for 2,000 off a separate piece of
her budget I know it but I didn't have
the tool like I know how I sell and I
know that there's opportunities and I
want to I want to have a product to sell
but like whatever it is and it might be
one to three products it might be one
product it might be a way we talk but by
South by definitely by can the three of
us are talking the same language ish
you know we alter it to the moment in
time but we are talking the three of us
are talking the same language and it
just becomes habit we hold because I've
got in the history and I understand
where I'm taking it so all what up log
trying to use my phone more this year
we're heading out here in Vegas kickin
Babbitt out cuz I got a media linked
party and then after meetings no reason
to happen hang out I'm gonna let him go
have some [ __ ] fun cuz you know
babban in Vegas creates a serious
combination of [ __ ] fun so while he
goes has fun I'm gonna go [ __ ] creep
foundational experiences I'm just gonna
go [ __ ] work
[Applause]
[Music]